hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sail israels
heute gibt's ein schwäbisches rezept und
zwar werde ich maultaschen machen
und ja der murat day schwabe genau wie
werde jetzt gucken ob eine working
schwäbische spätzle nicht spätzle
maultaschen und die maultaschen sind das
beliebteste schwäbisches rezept
überhaupt was genau alles obwohl wir
haben das rad wir haben fenster auf das
dach immer unten autos um kunden und
natürlich auch maultaschen ja so ist es
zwar mit dem alles erfunden natürlich
nicht aber das maultaschen rezept
verrate ich euch jetzt machen jetzt
erstmal den nudelteig selber das ist
zwar ein bisschen aufwand aber ich finde
es lohnt sich und vor allem kann man die
maultaschen auch gut vorbereiten so das
ist auch schon das motto stand die tür
und ich noch was also taten bereut
für den nudelteig brauche ich 500 gramm
mehl 500 gramm hartweizengrieß zehn eier
und zehn esslöffel olivenöl bei diesen
nudelteig habe ich jetzt mädel und
hartweizen gries einfach mit dem auto
schon ein bisschen bis fest bleiben und
nicht so weich werden
jetzt gebe ich die zwei trockenen
zutaten als e-mail und hartweizengrieß
in eine rührschüssel und entweder
verknetet ihr den teig jetzt mit den
händen oder mit der küchenmaschine aber
es ist natürlich ein sehr fester teig
der nudelteig und deswegen kann es ein
bisschen anstrengend werden die zutaten
jetzt kurz miteinander verrühren
jetzt kommen die eier mit dazu
und jetzt wird der teig gut durchgeführt
und durchgeknetet das macht ihr am
besten bei nicht so ganz hoher stufe
und da geht es gleich mit drei
der teig ist jetzt fertig geknetet und
es ist ein sehr kompakter teig natürlich
und ich brauchte auch wirklich keine
weitere flüssigkeit und auch kein
weiteres mehl
also bei mir saß am anfang ein bisschen
feucht draußen captain bisschen mehl
dazu war schon fast zu finden und den
teig werde ich jetzt noch abgedeckt
ruhen lassen und zwar stelle ich ihnen
noch mal für etwa eine halbe stunde in
den kühlschrank dann ist er gleich auch
ein bisschen elastischer und lässt sich
leichter verarbeiten und in der zeit
kann ich aber schon mal die füllung
vorbereiten
für die füllung brauche ich viel butter
8 2 knoblauchzehen 800 gramm hackfleisch
vom rind sechs eier
hier ein paar gewürze oregano petersilie
und rosmarin zwei brötchen die ich
bereits in wasser eingeweicht habe ein
kilo spinat salz und pfeffer und etwas
muskatnuss
das sieht jetzt natürlich noch sehr viel
aus aber wir machen ja auch eine große
menge
ich sehe jetzt zuerst einmal die zwiebel
habe ich schon geschält und halbiert und
die werden jetzt in feine würfel
geschnitten
das mache ich jetzt weil es einmal so
viele sind kurzem alligator aber können
natürlich auch ein ganz normales messer
verwendet möglich mit messer geht es
nicht besser
die butter gebe ich jetzt in einem
großen topf und sala sieht katrin kann
schon mal die zwiebeln mit rein geben
und die zwiebeln werden dann bei
mittlerer hitze zehn minuten langen es
angebraten dass er einfach ein bisschen
glasig werden aber es werden
verschmolzen zu den zwiebeln dazu kommt
jetzt das spiel natürlich alles noch
viel viel aus aber da fällt gleich
zusammen ich gebe ihnen zwei bis drei
portionen mit rein
deckel drauf und in 23 minuten fällt da
zusammen ich rühre um und gibt dann
gleich den rapper mit dazu und ich kann
jetzt hier schon mal alles andere
verwöhnt und so habe ich die kräuter
bereits fein geschnitten
da kommen auch die knoblauchzehen mit
dazu
dann kommt da das hackfleisch wird sein
die eier das brot ausdrücken und mir
dazu und zwar geht man jetzt brot und
spinat mit rein damit einfach die
führung nicht so fest und kompakt wird
sondern ein bisschen aufgelockert werden
und das tue ich jetzt schon mal oben und
gibt dann danach natürlich noch den
spinat mit dazu
der spinat ist jetzt auch zusammen
gefallen und ich habe ihnen bestimmt 20
minuten abkühlen lassen damit einfach
nicht mehr zu heiß ist und es kommt
jetzt hier mit dazu die flüssigkeit so
gut wie möglich abtropfen lassen
ausdrücken dass gut durchgemischt und
ich geb dir füllung jetzt gleich noch
mal durch den fleischwolf durch damit
sie einfach ein bisschen zerkleinert
gesetzt schon ziemlich grob und falls
ihr schon maultaschen gegessen habt
wisst ihr ja dass dieses gemüse brot
oder fleisch bilder drin richtig fein
ist
zum schluss gebe ich jetzt noch ein
brötchen durch den fleischwolf handy
gibt vor allem natürlich mit gedacht
habe ich aber nicht dann hätte ich
einfach die zwei brötchen nicht
eingeweicht und die zum schluss durch
gegeben hat einmal den vorteil dass der
fleischwolf sauber wird ins ganze
fleisch damit raus kommt und
andererseits ist jetzt die füllung ein
bisschen auch feucht weil einfach der
spinat noch sehr nass war und so können
uns einfach ein bisserl wieder trockener
bekommen
die füllung wird sich jetzt noch mit
muskatnuss salz und pfeffer
jetzt werden wir den nudelteig ausrollen
und dafür nehme ich erst mal mit
kleinere portion etwa ein drittel nach
auf mich ja du machst auch mit ob ich
meine große küchenhilfe geld enkel
getreulich den teig so ein bisschen aus
der pilot die maschine ein bisschen
einfacher es war fängt man da immer bei
der dicksten stärke an
und dann gehe ich immer weiter und
spielen wahrscheinlich bis auf stufe
sechs oder sieben um eine schöne gerade
platte hinzubekommen letzter zeit
mehrmals durch und falls ihnen dann
immer wieder nachbarn hier außen auch
schöne kannte
chips die teigplatten ein bisschen
gekürzt damit ich besser arbeiten kann
und jetzt wird sie mit der masse
bestrichen und zwar nur in der mitte und
dann dürfte sie jetzt nicht so voll
machen wie sehr die schwaben sind ein
bisschen spaß
der teig wird zu mit etwas wasser
bestrichen damit er gleich schön
zusammenklebt und die menschen dann auch
nicht aufgehen
und jetzt habe ich den unteren teil nach
oben
und das wird es nochmal drüber gelegt
und eignet sich so eine silikon matte
wirklich hervorragend jetzt nehmen die
einfachen gegenstand ein kochlöffel oder
silikon helfer und markiert jetzt die
einzelnen maultaschen die werden jetzt
eingedrückt damit ich sie gleich
abschalten kann
die maultaschen sind fertig also fertig
gerollt sage ich jetzt mal ich habe
jetzt hier welche und die anderen habe
ich im backofen gelagert jetzt fragt ihr
euch wahrscheinlich was macht sie mit
soviel im auto show
aber ihr könnt ihr jetzt zum beispiel
auch einfrieren das heißt ich will jetzt
dieses blech also die maultaschen
einfach auf dem backpapier ziehen und
einfrieren und sobald sie gefroren sind
kann man sehr wegnehmen und in den
beutel einparken oder in eine schüssel
und kann so einfach im lager noch immer
bei bedarf dann mal maultaschen
aufkochen
genau hier könnt ihr rechts
autoherstellers mit günstig ist
den spinat günstig ist genau und dann
kann man immer ganz günstig thematischen
herrschte ja gut und jetzt werden sie
gekocht und zwar hab ich sie ein
bisschen gemüsebrühe aufgekocht und ganz
typisch schwäbisch morath das vista
erkenne hier sind schmelz betriebe und
zwar habe ich jetzt hier butter und
zwiebelringe ein bisschen schmelzer
lassen
das ist nicht verordnung gibt für
schwäbische maultaschen oder schwäbische
maultaschen schwäbische maultaschen
nennen wenn sie nach der verhaftung gg
nach diesem verfahren herstellt nach
diesen kriterien
erst danach so die schwäbischen
maultaschen ich weiß ich hab mir die
verortung selber schaut euch gesehen die
menge special 55
und ich habe schon erzählte war hier mal
was erzählen ja als einem ganz kurz der
maultaschen die heißen schwäbischen auch
herr kurz scheiße
unser wahres herr kurz scheiße lag
diesmal ein blendendes wort er dort zwar
stärker auf keinem jahren es kommt daher
man an karfreitag darf man nur fisch
essen und damals aber trotzdem lust hat
er auf auf auf fleisch hatte dann aber
die dinger einfach eingepackt also hatte
den herd nicht beschissen weil er
man konnte ich sehe was drin ist
deswegen hält das ist eine herkunft und
die andere herkunft glaube dieses
überall die richtige ist es die
kontroll- und maultaschen und deswegen
ja deswegen heißen diese ja ich werde
jetzt hier in dem in der gemüsebrühe
garen und zwar kommen die jetzt ins
kochende wasser und dann stellt man den
herd aus und lässt sie einfach noch zwei
drei minuten ziehen
also das sind definitiv keine
schwäbischen maultasche 10 cm dicken
fertig ja online
ich glaube dessen keine maut wird seine
taschen also getötet also eigengewicht
stahlbauer taschen 40 bis 150 kam
wenn die maultaschen oben schon fertig
und jetzt können oder schon tot
jetzt kann man sie so schon essen so
sind sie auch sehr lecker aber noch
besser werden sie wenn man sie noch hier
in die butter mit rein gibt noch ein
bisschen mit andres doch einfach die
zwiebeln auf eine seite nehmen und die
maultaschen ist von jeder seite kurz
anbraten
bradley sondern man sich im schwarzwald
lag und jetzt gibt's monats angebratene
maultaschen
sie muss schließen zwar auf demo ist nur
wenig und zwiebeln also ich finde
triebel die müsse unbedingt mehr dazu
und sehr untypisch sage ich jetzt mal
aber typisch schwäbisch kommt noch ein
kartoffelsalat meter zur person mit
schwäbischen also man immer ganz ehrlich
was normalerweise der schwäbische
cardoso schön geld da ist es halt noch
besser da sind dass die zwiebel mit drin
die angebraten sind also normalerweise
fließt wieder angemacht mit essig und öl
und den an gebratenen zwiebeln und der
so leicht säuerlich also maultaschen
ganz ehrlich müssen die man geplant sei
nicht angebracht sein anbieter haben
seite braten eine angebraten okay sind
toll aus und der konsistenz her
klitschnass und fleisch fisch pasta dass
sein nein ich hab so macht jeder
waschechter schwabe zubereiten wird so
nicht zuviel füllungen zeigen wir der
stufe wollen
probier's mal
vielleicht wissen in der brühe alles gut
falls nicht dann erschieße ich habe
genug salz und geht noch ein bisschen
wie gehören schweren für das problem ist
wenn man zuviel füllung reinmacht krieg
bei dem motto natürlich nicht mehr so
gut so deswegen muss man eben immer
gucken dass man nicht zu viel füllungen
rein und mache auf jeden fall noch salz
in gemüsebrühe ihr müsst minutentakt hat
mir kein salz mehr drin weil er
ansonsten zu fest wird und dann kommt
einfach immer ganz viel salz in die
gemüsebrühe und dann zieht das
puzzleteil das salz bisserl ein super
aber wie gesagt die maultaschen die
müsste mehr für das mittel sei und der
muss doch wirklich okay angebracht sind
etwas anders als support verwechselt die
angebrachten das sind nur ein bisschen
härter und die gehen auch müssen die
hitze aber wie gesagt mehr fülle auf
jeden fall und schwäbischer segel drauf
fordert es überhaupt da draußen kann ich
für ihre schwedischen aber gut immer
apathischer wäre also falls sie jetzt
lust bekommen habt auf den maultaschen
auf die badischen maultaschen dann
schaut auf meinem blog auf verließ -
blog.de da steht das rezept noch mal
ganz genau für euch und falls ihr nicht
20 personen versorgung wollt dann macht
einfach die hälfte des rezepts oder er
macht so wie ich und fährt einfach ein
teil davon 1
also viel spaß beim nachmachen und wir
sehen uns das nächste mal bis dann mit
vollem mund spricht man